The Joe Rogan experience.
How are you?
It's fine.
I'm good.
I'm pouring coffee in the first seconds.
Perfect chat.
That's the good way to do it.
With a Gif of tea.
Can we?
Yeah,
I think it is named in a fringe way.
A French Press.
That's what they're called.
Is it called?
Well it's called,
I think it's called cafeteria,
but it's probably got a pot of coffee.
But that makes sense.
But you know,
there's a French word for it that we just ignore him.
They did a,
meant a lot of the food,
you know,
cause you have,
um,
herbs,
you know,
herbs.
And I used to do this bit of a too,
which I really enjoyed seeing.
You know,
the difference between British and American.
You say this,
you say and you say herbs and we say Herb's because there's a fucking h in it.
And I used to cause a fucking age,
but,
and I thought,
well why is the h dropped off for America?
I think it's because,
but a lot of French guys would come over to immigration and they would have done
a lot of cooking,
you know,
so these fish guys know about cooking and they do the elves and they,
they cut the h off.
Totally.
So I think that was an influence from that.
Probably Julia Child,
Julia,
Joe,
she French I think,
wasn't she?
She is now.
I mean,
usually the French cooking.
All right.
Okay,
well then maybe that way you sit next to Washington and say,
we will use our herbs with the staff here and then we could do the revolutionary
war and then a,
and then you'd guys a win and then they will hate each other forever.
Well,
you ask,
you guys also do a lot of weird stuff where you put like a,
you in color and you have a why and tires.
What are you putting in ties open I res.
Yeah,
I think we had,
we had first dibs on the laggers.
Yeah.
I don't understand what we did.
Do they know what you got on the,
uh,
your guys got on the Mayflower and they said,
okay,
we're going to talk like this for was gonna say,
whew.
A lot and we're going to get put,
get rid of the Y in tires.
If we're going to invent the tires,
get rid of the one.
Yeah.
I just think theU and color and honor is a you and honor as well.
And we've got it and you've got it out and I think yours is more logical on
honor.
Yeah.
But not for Herb's now herbs is more French influence.
I agree.
Yeah.
I always wondered because I grew up in Boston and I always wondered like those
were the first people to leave England and Europe.
Like what the fuck happened to their language because they developed the most
disgusting brand of it.
Well,
you've got your A's,
you're busted days,
which I kind of had a strong Boston coming out of you.
Yeah,
I got rid of it.
All right.
I heard myself on television once when I was like 19 years old.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
What is that?
Well you guys had or why we used to have uh,
their mother,
father,
brother said,
yeah,
Fan cat.
Yeah.
And we say mother,
but the father,
sister,
we don't have an r at the end of our mother,
brother,
father,
sister and you know that yeah.
We say mother instead of mother and the rest of America has,
it has a much stronger and island has that.
That's a very Irish influenced thing.
And for us the eye when we playing,
when I'm playing American,
when I was in,
you know,
doing roles like that,
the are was the hardest thing to get hard,
hard tar.
I remember friends saying,
Hey,
I was cranking this thing and it came out like hard,
hard tar and I thought that is the one that practice because that is just hard,
hard tar.
We'd call it hot hot tower,
which is just doesn't sound the same.
You spend a lot of time over you.
I've only,
the only,
the only time I've ever spent in uh,
England is working,
uh,
like a little bit of downtime doing stand up and hang out over there.
But most of it,
it's just been working either working for the UFC here,
I'd never been really get a chance to really spend time in England.
I'd like to,
I'd like to do that just to kind of understand you folks.
Well,
I are different breed when the,
I think at the base having played 45 countries now,
I think everyone is actually the same when you get down below a level,
but you know if you're going to reach for you,
there's gotta be a number of things which would make it seem different in brand
names will be different than the sport stars.
You know,
everyone's sports does everyone's policies if you have that kind of thing,
but underneath it all,
it's going to be,
there's going to be more mainstream.
People are going to be alternative people.
There's going to be,
and the whole spectrum now,
like in the old days it used to be everything was mainstream then a bit of
alternative.
Now we,
I think your country market,
we have a whole spectrum of what's interest.
People is much more open in that way.
Yeah,
no,
I certainly agree.
We,
yeah,
it's the collection of people is very similar.
It's just they're operating in a different environment in different theater.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
we are tightly smashed together.
Would it be 65 million and your 300 million and you're such a large,
your country is so large compared to us.
Yeah.
Um,
cause there was this thing of 10,
only 10% of Americans have possibles.
But if you look at the through,
something like that,
but then if you look at where the 10% can go in America,
it's just so huge.
So it's slightly more understandable why a lot of Americans say,
I don't need a possible cause.
I can just going to go to that place,
which is miles away.